filmmaker Rob Reiner has spent months
sounding the alarm about Russia last
fall he helped make that video and of
course he is very excited about today's
indictments today he tweeted this quote
it's now crystal clear that Russia had a
profound impact on the 2016 election
they have attacked us they're continuing
to attack us if Trump is unwilling to
acknowledge us unwilling to protect us
the word treason is now center stage Rob
Reiner joins us tonight Rob good to see
ya hey Tucker how you doing I'm doing
great I would think that after reading
this series of indictments the one that
say the Russians supported Trump
attacked Hillary the Russians also
supported black lives matter and Bernie
the Russians also had an anti Trump
rally in front of Trump Tower you'd be a
little embarrassed by tweets like this
and your hysteria generally are you know
not you know but here's the thing the
Tucker everybody out there knows that
you you and I are on opposite sides of
the political spectrum I mean that's
that we all know that so what I'm what
I'm thinking right now is you and I
together because we're so far apart
politically we have an opportunity here
to do a great service to the country if
if if all we have to do and this is not
about whether or not there's collusion
or whether or not whatever the Russians
did definitely or didn't affect the
outcome of the election all you and I
have to do at this point is agree with
what rod Rosen Stein said today do you
agree with that or no I guess I mean I
don't know I mean yeah I don't like
foreign countries meddling in our
affairs I don't like that you tailor
your movies to the Chinese censors
specifications as you know you do so I
don't like any kind of foreign
interference at all I find it all
offensive I'm just saying when you
accuse somebody of treason I've come out
against McCarthyism and to see you
engage in it treason unpatriotic you use
phrases like that why would you do that
no no I I didn't accuse him of treason
what I said she did
no no what I said was if he is refusing
to acknowledge the fact that the
Russians did attack us during the
election and if he refuses to do
anything about it then you're conspiring
with an enemy and that's that's all I'm
okay but can I just wear that okay you
want something to do but we're now
killing Russians in Syria Trump killed a
bunch of him last week were you happy
about that were you excited that he
killed Russians I I'm not talking about
we're not talking about the Russians in
Syria or what happened it's here we're
talking about were you excited he killed
Russians in Syria what did you think of
that yeah IIIi don't have an opinion
about that I know all I know is what no
I don't all I know is what has happened
is that we've been invaded and they
continue to do to try to disrupt our
democracy and like you just pointed out
early you know they'll go on both sides
they'll try to help Bernie Jill Stein
the Russian thinks is disrupt I think
the Russians have more influence in our
country than the Chinese government to
which you routinely kowtow in your films
do you thought to see you look at the
camera to the Russians have more effect
the more effect on American society than
the Chinese government do you believe
that but wait a minute why did you say
that I kowtow to them in my film because
Hollywood films as you know would never
have a flattering portrayal of the Dalai
Lama for example because the Russian
because the Chinese government doesn't
want it American American films are
routinely censored or they go along with
the the imperatives of the Chinese
government censors you know this you
live there I mean but you're asking you
saying that I censor myself for the
Chinese I don't do that I don't know
what else happened huh from everybody
else but all I'm saying to her well I
don't but here's the thing Tucker all
I'm saying is if you and I can agree all
we have to do is agree that the Russians
tried to meddle and disrupt our
democracy that's all we have to agree on
if we can agree on I've thought that for
years
I thought the Rosenbergs were guilty I
you know what I mean I'm serious I'm I
think the Russians have done that for
years I think many countries do it yes
they do do it right they do do it and
the Russians have been doing it for
years the only difference between what
they have done which is they call active
measures and disinformation campaigns
the only difference between what they've
been doing for years and now is that
it's on steroids because of the internet
and because of social media so it's a
much more powerful effect of what
they've been able to accomplish right
now you agree that you probably
shouldn't call people unpatriotic or
treasonous on your Twitter account can
we just stop with agree on that note
well I wouldn't say they're unpatriotic
or treasonous unless they're not willing
to protect our country against foreign
enemy powers that's all and let's see
what maybe he will maybe he'll change
his mind
maybe he'll maybe he'll will be a
patriot in your mind all right we're
gonna we're out of time Rob thank you
for doing that appreciate okay all right